thank you for joining us we begin with
breaking news from the u.s has been a
mass shooting
in florida at least two people have been
killed and 20
injured in the city of miami police say
three attackers shot indiscriminately
into a large crowd
let's go straight to miami and andy
gallagher who's there for us andy what
more do we know
well this shooting happened in the early
hours of sunday morning outside a
banquet hall
that uh is being reported that was
rented out for a rap concert what we do
know is that
three men pulled up in a white suv
walked out of that vehicle with a
mixture of assault rifles and pistols
and
indiscriminately shot into the crowd
that was gathered outside that concert
hall killing two people and injuring at
least
20. there were some reports saying that
25 people were injured at least one of
those
critically some of those people that
were injured drove themselves
to local hospitals across the city but
the chief of police saying he thinks
this was a
targeted cold-blooded shooting in a
miami neighborhood so we're still
waiting for more details the police
obviously are now looking at
footage from the area to try and
identify the three suspected shooters in
this case but this is the second
shooting
this memorial day weekend here in miami
there was another one on saturday night
in which one person was killed
and six others injured and of course
this is the latest
in a spree of mass shootings as this
country begins to emerge
from the covert 19 pandemic right and i
was going to ask you about that there's
been
a surge in gun violence in the u.s this
year president biden calling it a
national embarrassment
what are the reasons behind this
increase and what's being done to stop
it
well the reasons behind it are always
very complex but it seems that as people
come out of the covert 19 pandemic
remember
that entire year the pandemic was
sweeping across this country gun
violence was generally down and as
people returned to normal life
unfortunately this is normal life in
this country
we had a mass shooting in california
just a few days ago
there was a mass shooting in georgia at
a a series of massage parlors
it just keeps going on and on now
president biden is trying to tackle this
by introducing legislation to for
instance
ban 3d printed guns but essentially he's
up he's fighting a losing battle because
the republicans will never pass anything
that challenges the second amendment
but yet again we see the shooter in
california with thousands of bullets
extended magazines
and this this pandemic in itself this
gun violence pandemic just seems to
continue going
on despite calls for action so
unfortunately
in the grand scheme of things what
happened here in the early hours of
sunday morning
is on a smaller scale than what the
shootings we've seen in the past
as for what lawmakers will do about
curtailing this kind of gun violence
well that's just a question i've been
answering for the last 15 years and the
answer always seems to be
nothing andy gallagher in miami thank
you very much andy